[Musique]
ils ont fait la une de l'actualité
les médias visant starifié voir ce cas
tu fier on ne parlait que d'eux on ne
voyait qu'eux et puis jour au lendemain
ils ont quitté l'éphémère panthéon de la
gloire mais berne les projos de l'info
ont éclairé ailleurs elle public les
apps est aussi vite qu'ils avaient
quittée l'incognito elles sont retourné
à l'anonymat qui était-il d'où
venaient-ils pourquoi et comment avait
il a killer célébrités de quelle façon
eux et leurs proches avait t-il vécu
lors des mariages pour quelles raisons
ils disent pas exact que s'est il passé
depuis bref que sont-ils dans tout le
monde en a parlé à travers d'abord des
archives de la gloire puis une enquête
sur leur vie aujourd'hui et enfin une
interview vérité je vais vous raconter
leur histoire voici tout le monde va
parler l'émission qui rallume l'année
[Musique]
j'accueille julie pietri
et
[Musique]
musique6
après du sourire l on veut
dix jours
plus
tôt
non
il
alors
oh
la vedette qui ce soir a réussi son
retour
gagnant jeudi
après sa victoire dans l'émission retour
gagnant en 2003 s'est arrêté sans
quelle musique joue les salles un
passage remarqué au bataclan en 2007
[Musique]
la sortie en 2009 de son livre
témoignage sur les grandes étapes de sa
vie
en 2011 julie piétri rejoint la tournée
âge tendre et tête de bois c'est la
première saison que je fais avec un
jeton c'est un plaisir un donneur je
suis tellement fière
[Musique]
aujourd'hui tout le monde en a parlé et
partie dans l'est de la france font
retrouver julie piétri quelques heures
avant son concert je prends chez toi
tu m'a préparé ça laisse italienne
[Musique]
ce soir donc on est dans un casino à
bussang
loin que nancy et voilà chez un garçon
chez lequel j'ai déjà pour le cas j'ai
déjà chanté
dans d'autres casino casino tranchant
notamment à yport deux fois et voilà
c'est toujours un moment de qualité à un
moment où on s'amuse bien et
où on fait des voix là on est accueilli
avec bonheur
avant son entrée en scène ce soir julie
tient à tout préparer l'artiste fait
sémalens sous les yeux du directeur du
casino et de son équipe technique
et
oh
on voit la répétition des fêtes attend
ben jawad j'ai faim j'en peux plus
[Musique]
c'est l'heure la salle se remplit
jusqu'à la dernière place et c'est parti
pour deux heures de concert et de
bonheur pour la chanteuse aux plus de 12
millions de disques elle invite même le
directeur du casino à monter sur scène
avec elle le temps d'une chanson
[Applaudissements]
c'est une tradition pour elle à la fin
d'un concert julie les peut partir sans
remercier son public
le plus formidable vraiment génial
[Musique]
après on prend la photo aux aucune
dépense qui les photos de julie pietri
oui c'est une chanteuse
ch.d j'ai bien parti ils sont
constamment
aujourd'hui encore sa voix si
particulière attire toutes les
générations fidèle à son public julie
est aussi fidèle à son équipe et à
francine qu'il accompagne partout je
suis ce qu'on appelle des oeuvres
d'artistes
je m'occupe d'eux de az j'ai conduit
vérifiez que la scène soit bien
installée gens voient les bandes
les répétitions depuis trois ans tu veux
à faire une soixantaine de gala parents
ont fini par être complice c
c'est maintenant de l'amitié que tu
travailles pas le temps de traîner julie
un avion à prendre direction les
antilles pour se transformer en actrice
le temps du tournage d'hôtel caraïbes
une série territoire très très tôt je
dois refaire vite ma valise pour partir
à l'île saint martin pour jouer dans
cette série et donc voilà quelques
heures de sommeil
des bagages on fait comment peur mais
tout comme ça hambourg tout et on
reprend l'avion à roissy pour 9 heures
d'avion
bail
[Musique]
et maintenant la lumière se rallume sur
julie piétri d'hui bienvenue sur plateau
tu m'en a parlé vous êtes né le 1er mai
1957 à doué rats dans la banlieue
d'alger sous le nom de nicole juliette
pietri père xavier est dans l'agronomie
et votre mère denise et femmes au foyer
alors enfance assez traumatisante à
cause de ce qu'on a appelé les
événements d'algérie mais qu'ils ont
fait était une guerre vous dit les
bombes qui font exploser les vitres les
corps qui gisent dans les ruelles le
sang qui coule dans les rigoles ça vous
a profondément marqué partout dans le
monde je crois que ce que les gens qui
naissent dans une guerre sont marqués à
vie le tout est de transformer tout ça
en bonheur de vivre
alors autre cause du traumatisme
les rapports complexes que vous
entretenez avec votre mère en fait elle
n'avait pas connu sa mère à elle qui
était morte en accouchant et vous dites
chez les pietri on communiquait pas on
se confier pas ans plaignez pas c'était
très dur maman était né dans la campagne
d'algérie donc la campagne d'algérie
comme temps toute bonne campagne surtout
à une certaine époque c'est quand même
très très hard as été élevé à la dure
sans être aimé puisque son papa elle
avait accusé d'avoir fait mourir sa
maman voilà à l'époque les césariennes
n'était pas soigné y'avait pas
d'antibiotiques et c'est donc
c'était très très dur très lo et
voilà et mon papa travailler beaucoup et
chercher à nous protéger tout en
laissant un peu dans cette guerre
d'algérie qui je pense s'était pas faite
pour les enfants alors en 1962 après
l'indépendance de l'algérie comme des
milliers de pieds noirs d'être rapatrié
en métropole
votre famille transitent par la savoie
ensuite le petit quevilly votre père a
trouvé un emploi de commercial agronome
et là il retourne pendant quatre ans au
maroc dont vous vous retrouver de
nouveau en afrique du nord pendant
quatre ans ouais avec un grand plaisir
par
c'était c'était l'algérie sur la guerre
donc le maroc gaza s'étaient casablanca
on avait surtout ce folklore qu'on
aimait le mélange des cultures le
mélange des religions j'ai adoré être
là-bas malheureusement mon papa il a
très vite perdu un peu la tête et
pensant que j'allais voir le couvre feu
allez avoir des tanks ou des blindés
militaires ou qui allait avoir les
fellaghas enfin bon il était
complètement
traumatisée et quelques années plus tard
finalement tout est art surgi j'ai donc
vu mon papa est ce un héros pleurer sur
son volant de voitures et donc là
c'était fichu il fallait rentrer au
retour vous vous installez opecst dans
la banlieue de saint germain en laye
c'est là que j'allais passer votre
adolescence une adolescence assez
violente parce que vous dites au lycée
on me traitait de sale arabe de sale
juive le sale pieds noirs de salles
colonialiste c'est pas facile pour les
pieds noirs oui j'avais tout c'était un
multi mode comme ça c'était du n'importe
quoi c'est à l'adolescence que vous
décidez de remplace celikkol par
juliette qui votre deuxième prénom et
puis ensuite juliette pas julie toujours
à l'adolescence vous commencé à vous
intéresser à la musique vous êtes incité
par votre frère jean qui vous amène à
des concerts de jazz et à 15 ans vous
formez votre premier groupe julie france
était bon il y avait quelque chose qui
m'échappe et à l'époque sur ce nom mais
bon moi je pensais aux avions et aux
salles d'eau salle de transit voilà et
donc c'était un bon groupe qui était pas
très heureux moi j'ai fait un peu marre
émission
avec avec la musique en j'oublié tous
les coups que je recevais au lycée parce
que j'ai pris quelques bons coups mais
je les ai rendu 1 ça m'arrive j'étais
très bagarreuse ça m'a vraiment aidé à
rendre coup pour coup il ya peut-être à
devenir un peu une combattante dans le
bon sens du terme cette énergie là vous
la mettre dans la musique elle même dans
la musique chantée du véronique sanson
du janis joplin
janis joplin joe cocker j'avais déjà
voilà j'avais déjà dans l'idée que je
deviendrais chanteuse savait pas trop
comment oui parce que pour le moment
après le bac pour faire plaisir à votre
père vous êtes obligés d'obtenir votre
diplôme d'orthophonistes avant de
continuer la chanson quoi voilà donc
papa m'a dit je te coupe les vivres qui
était déjà c'est pas c'était pas l'ours
qui me donnait par semaine et cynthia
pas de ton diplôme ben voila tu es tu es
viré je vais passer je les passais en
même temps je passer une audition pour
entrer dans un groupe voilà pour enfant
qui s'appelle la bande à béni oui oui
absolument et vous avez enregistré un
premier tube qui s'appelle magdalena ça
commence très fort j'imaginais pas on
avait été trois solistes dont une fille
du big bazar et c'est à écouter cette
maquette et les deux sont partis les
deux autres sont partis en disant c'est
vraiment de la houe et ça ne va pas du
tout c'est très mauvais moi je demande à
réécouter cette maquette jeudi mais ça
me reste dans la tête je sais pas si
c'est ça que je veux faire de ma
carrière je ne sais absolument pas mais
je trouve que c'est ça m'a l'air très
fort et j'ai fait ce premier ce premier
disque en disant moi je veux bien faire
un premier disque mais à condition que
si ça commence à marcher je puisse avoir
un album j'étais déjà un peu roues et un
peu rusé et on va dire oui d'accord ok
ok ok puis puis moi je suis parti à
ibiza et puis pendant que j'étais à
ibiza il paraît qu on me cherchait
partout il y avait pas là il n'y avait
pas la technologie moderne y avait pas
de voile a pas de portable avait rien du
tout on va chercher partout parce que
le disque commencé à fonctionner très
bien fonctionné c'est devenu un tube
vous fait l'olympia premier disque d'or
et je fais l'olympia grâce à monsieur
sacha distel qui me remarque qui aime
bien d'avoir un physique et qui m'a pris
sous son aile et là ça va bien parce
qu'avant votre gros tubes vous avez déjà
vendu six millions de disques avant
celui qui va marquer
les esprits durablement j'ai eu j'ai eu
voilà j'ai vendu six millions de disques
et sous son seul prénom je pense que je
rattraperai un peu plus tard je
m'applique j'évite tout court julie tout
court ce qui me gênait beaucoup et là
c'est le carton de votre carrière eve
lève-toi numéro 1 au top 50 qui restait
classé pendant six mois ça c'est
vraiment le méga tube j'étais chez
claude carrière ça ne me convenait pas
j'ai tout larguer et y compris mais
royalties en lui disant je veux
récupérer mon contrat je te laisse tout
j'ai tout laissé et j'étais à la
recherche d'autres choses y compris
rechercher mon nom de famille et
retrouver mon nom de famille comme nom
d'artiste est vraiment recherché mes
racines au travers d'un texte qui
meurent sans que je signe avec
jean-michel béria et on cherchait un
jeune compositeur et ce jeune
compositeur je vais le trouver dans sa
cave à enghien les bains et là on a
travaillé jour et nuit et on a on a créé
ce morceau eve lève-toi et voilà et ça a
été quelque chose qui moi me convenait
très bien parce que ça me permettait de
prouver que je m'étais relevé des
expériences précédentes artistiquement
et
voilà qui me montrait un peu comme la
combattante que j'avais toujours été et
surtout gertrude aussi dans moins de
familles ce qui me plaisait bien c'est
la célébrité quelles ont été les
réactions de votre entourage votre
famille déjà au la papaye déjà était
déjà convaincu que j'allais
que j'avais comme on dit j'ai les corses
tes stades que j'avais une taie stade
houphouet voilà ce que je suis moitié
corse moitié pieds-noirs et c'est vrai
que papa trouvé que j'avais voilà un
chemin
et que j'en parle j'ai ma personne et
que j'avais un chemin personnel j'ai
toujours été un peu comme un comment
vous dire un peu comme un électron libre
je n'ai jamais demandé conseil à
personne j'étais un peu solitaire une
artiste assez solitaire qui n'a jamais
fait partie d'une famille en particulier
ni d'un voilà j'ai jamais cherché à
avoir la carte pas avoir la carte je
m'en foutais et vos copains vos amis
je sais pas et je savais j'ai très peu
goûté le succès de eve et de tout cet
album à toute cette période parce que
j'avais un sentiment beaucoup d'artistes
vous diront d'être un peu pressé comme
un citron salut je sortais d'un drucker
et on me mettez trois bureaux 11 ans
dans un coca cola pour que j'aille
rejoindre musiciens sur scène à 100
bornes de là c'était extraordinaire est
à la fois j'avais l'impression d'être
sur une espèce de nuages que je
n'appréhendais pas vraiment les médias
ont été sympa avec vous je vais pas me
plaindre en fait j'ai jamais donné
vraiment beaucoup de choses aux médias
parce que encore une fois je leur
donnais peu à manger y avait peu à
grignoter chez moi je gagne de l'argent
non beaucoup et la mort est ce que cette
célébrité vous a rapporté des conquêtes
ah c'est pas si simple quand on est une
fille quand on est une femme on tombe
sur deux cas de figure soit des mecs qui
sont assez je dirais pervers narcissique
qui veulent le pouvoir sur vous et qui
n'accepte pas que vous en ayez un peu
soit vous tombez sur des lâches qui fuit
en courant je n'ose pas dire entre
guillemets la queue entre les jambes
mais bon ça a été plutôt le ce parcours
là que j'ai eu dans l'amour et voilà
donc c'était ce n'était pas facile que
été le meilleur moment de cette époque
plusieurs faire un olympia à guichets
fermés pendant huit jours parce que je
me suis rendu compte que si c'était
overbooké pendant huit jours la façon
dont je le prenais peut-être je le
retrouverais un jour
le pire moment le pire moment le moment
où j'ai fait une
virée entre guillemets une tentative de
suicide parce que mon compagnon de
l'époque avec lequel j'avais
cc ma relation ne supportait pas que ce
soit un simple enceinte ça sur le
producteur avec qui vous avez partagé
dix ans de votre vie voilà vous le
quittez vous rencontrer un autre homme
vous tomber enceinte mais lui va voir
celer en règle il comprend pas pourquoi
vous êtes enfin d'un autre quoi ces
sales histoires histoires ça qui m'a
proposé même le mariage une sorte de
trio ouais on a joué on aurait joué à
judge him away moi je ne voulais pas
comme ça parce que j'avais vécu une
histoire très très très belle est à la
fois tragiques avec cet homme-là qui
était un peu pervers est un peu violent
et qui me harceler moralement mais avant
aussi mais à ce moment là ça a été une
horreur j'ai fait une tentative de
suicide
ce qui était juste une façon de dire
halte au harcèlement que de vouloir
vraiment mûri que je portais la vie
voilà j'imagine que quand on est
enceinte on annonce il est donc c'était
pour en finir avec les tourments qu'il
vous infligeant mais j'en ai eu marre
j'ai pris quelques médicaments trop ce
qui s'est passé donc tentative de
suicide le père du bébé vous trouvé
assez tôt pour qu'un lavage d'estomac
suffisent à vous sauver et malgré
l'effroyable pronostic de votre
producteur qui vous dit le bébé va
mourir ou bébé ne sera pas normal le
bébé est sain et sauf finalement voilà
elle va très bien évidemment j'ai tout
fait tout ce qu'il fallait à mieux
synthèse j'ai fait tout ce qu'il fallait
j'avais confiance en la vie me donner
cet enfant qui serait la seule je le
savais pas ce que au fond si j'ai envoyé
mon contrat chez sony c'est que le
monsieur qui m'avait
opéré j'ai fait la microchirurgie
pendant quatre heures et demie pour
avoir cette enfant
a suivi ma grossesse et m'a dit je te
signale que je vous signale que si
vous continuez à faire le des concerts
comme ça et à faire la route vous allez
perdre votre enfant à cinq six mois et
il en était pas question je savais que
je n'aurais qu'un enfant l'enfant va
bien l'info va bien elle est
effectivement à huit mois seulement de
grossesse mais c'est pas grave avec
quelques ennuis aux hanches etc mais
j'ai fait face je fais face pendant dix
ans alors là vous entre un avis ça va
durer neuf ans et vous comprenez en fait
que la guerre a laissé des traces
profondes et que c'est ça qui a exacerbé
votre vulnérabilité par rapport à à cet
homme entre autres oui je pense qu'il y
avait un côté
victimisation un idéal
pour prédateurs ont trop facile pour un
homme adam théorique un peu abusif tout
à fait tout à fait je pense que voilà
c'est pour ça que j'ai souvent mais
pendant longtemps je vois de temps à
autres encore ben may j'ai changé depuis
plusieurs fois mais ma chère madame
freud que j'aime énormément à dire qu'en
fait votre père quand il est allé au
maroc la guerre lui est revenue et vous
c'est au moment de notre pic analyse ou
ou ses remontées vous avez ma grossesse
était remonté à partir du moment où tu
as fait c'est fait cette tentative je
dirais
de suicide entre guillemets c'est pas
vraiment ça que j'ai voulu faire mais
enfin bon
et que j'attendais cet enfant et qu'ils
avaient tous ces problèmes autour de moi
cet homme un peu prédateur s'est posé
des questions graves vraiment des
questions graves sur la petite enfance
sur pourquoi et là j'ai entamé un vrai
boulot j'ai aussi fait je suis rentré
aussi au cours florent pour voir si je
ne savais pas c'est à autre chose que de
la musique voilà puisque j'étais j'avais
pu être orthophoniste je vous j'avais pu
être chanteuse je voulais savoir si
j'avais pouvait parfois aussi
être comédien louis alors aujourd'hui
vous êtes nostalgique de cette époque de
eve lève-toi pas du tout pas du tout pas
du tout pas du tout je trouve que je vis
bien mieux ce que j'avais aujourd'hui et
depuis que j'ai mon nom et puis aussi
depuis que je suis revenu à un certain
moment voilà vous avez la rancune contre
quelqu'un est cet homme en particulier
je trouve que s'enfermer dans des
pensées négatives est quelque chose qui
me qui m'intéressent tellement pas ça
m'empêchera d'aller de l'avant
déménageant je savais j'ai j'adore les
humains j'adore les de découvrir et
finalement aujourd'hui j'ai peut-être
plus envie de parler que avant mon
analyse n'en voulait pas pas du tout
alors j'étais à refaire votre vie julie
qu'est-ce que vous ne feriez pas pareil
la seule chose que je logeais un regret
c'est d'avoir manqué comme dirait
laurent gerra d'un harnais avec moi ce
que je pense que j'aurais pu être une
une chanteuse plus
pas la chanteuse dont on dit elle a fait
magdalena elle a fait ça l'a fait ça
quelques incidents quelques carrières
pense que j'aurais même pu faire une
carrière c'était peut-être peut-être
mais bon c'est je m'en fous quelque part
aussi parce que
l'avenir m'attend l'avenir n'attend
j'adore le jour vous allez mourir que
tous les cons marc chauveau de tombes
écoutez on va rien marqué puisque je
vais être incinérés et que simplement
j'aimerais que maintenant en cachette
heidi côtés de l'algérie la tunisie et
du maroc
répondre mais cendres dans la
méditerranée
merci je lis tous très heureux de
relever merci aussi à vous merci
beaucoup
[Musique]
j'accueille mehdi
il y avait au fil
des trois ok
tu sais mon maison il ya plein de choses
à manger suis toujours ma voiture je
rêve de remonter au 20
tu sais chez moi il ya un prêt il ya
plein de clubs l'été l'elysée n'est pas
une blague alors qu'il y aura dans un
vagin
et on va
[Musique]
oh
e
pourquoi du comment
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tout le monde en a parlé à retrouver
l'acteur et réalisateur mehdi à la
terrasse d'un café parisien est en
pleine lecture matinale moi j'aime bien
de tenir au courant générale de tout ce
qui se passe dans la la veille donc
l'oeil à l'envers en fait parce que il
ya les séries de théâtre c'est un
réflexe de parisiens le journal pour
nous
et sinon bah c'est la moto un
old school mois en matière de moto
pas trop de plastiques beaucoup de
ferraille et beaucoup de chrome
[Musique]
je suis mon agent
parce que génial c'est que mon père
c'est le crazy c'est juste à côté
pas génial ça
ryanair la mort babette pouget crantage
ans
[Musique]
c'est très bien
babet est un agent très connu dans le
milieu elle suit nombre d'acteurs et
notamment mes dix depuis quarante maman
était même agence il ya très longtemps
donc on s'était croisé à cette occasion
un peu grâce à laurent baffie oui
oui accueilli très gentiment banon mais
c'était normal
telenor c'est très important d'avoir un
agent à qui on s'entend bien l écluse
activités qui vous aiment un peu
[Musique]
un jour tu entends parler d'un fidel
castro d'un tournage tu as ça le fait
quand même en cassation du maire je
crois que la prod t'envoyer médecine ans
à oui alors il vous de ce duo on va
regarder attend en garde voilà ce que je
n'ai pas vu moi encore un support milla
tu vas voir c'est formidable il s'agit
du making of du remake de belle et
sébastien réalisé par le célèbre
aventurier nicolas vanier film dans
lequel mehdi fait une apparition et
c'est très particulier pour moi c'est un
retour c'est on tend vers le futur
je retourne le 50 ans en arrière
en même temps c'est très différent
très touchante pour la traite a retiré
son
côté l'image est magnifique en tout cas
c'est beau
courant oui c'était bien là vraiment je
suis bien contente au bâton ailleurs
très content comme saisonniers plus que
voilà exactement une grosse mise à jour
son lot de matin je n'ai même pas
commencé à bientôt un nouveau
bond qui nominer la bombe et poussé la
fin de journée j'ai peut-être le temps
d'aller voir un pote concessionnaire
moto un truc super
s'il n'est pas fermée je vais foncer là
bas
et dès le lendemain il retourne au pays
bars où il réside depuis quelques années
par ordinateur
[Musique]
et maintenant la lumière se rallume sur
mehdi mehdi bienvenue sur le plateau de
tout le monde un regard et alors vous
êtes né le 26 mai 1956 à choisy-le-roi
sous le nom de mehdi el masry el glaoui
en fait votre père sim brahim el glaoui
était le fils du pacha de marrakech et
pendant la période du protectorat
français en fait le le pacha de
marrakech avait une certaine autonomie
il s'est retrouvé effectivement à avoir
la charge de toute une région assez
vaste qui comprenait le sud du maroc le
pays berbère la montagne et c est donc
comme il était très à l'époque pour les
français et ami des français le pouvoir
local français lyautey notamment s'est
beaucoup appuyé sur lui et sur ses
troupes pour pacifier entre guillemets
le sud du maroc y voilà à voir en 1956
au moment de l'indépendance du maroc
mohamed 5 rentrer de son exil à
madagascar et à ce moment là c'est votre
père qui part en exil en france voilà
voilà bon la famille globalement et plus
ou moins banni mon père était très
engagé auprès de mon grand-père est donc
effectivement il a été condamné à l'exil
pendant 15 ans voilà alors votre maire
cécile aubry et cécile aubry c'était une
ravissante comédienne aux yeux vert
bronze et à la moue boudeuse vraiment
magnifique et henri georges clouzot
avait fait d'elle une star dans un film
qui s'appelait manon absolument
maintenant obtient le lion d'or à la
mostra de venise en 1949 donc c'est dire
la popularité de votre mère à l'époque
alors elle signe alors un contrat avec
la twenty century fox pour un film qui
s'appelle la rose noire d'henry hathaway
avec orson welles et tyrone power c'est
quand même pas mal et c'est pendant le
tournage de la rose noire donc en 1950
dans les dunes de la classe marocain
qu'elle rencontre votre père donc le
fils aîné du pacha de marrakech il vient
visiter le plateau en fait il était
caïds
et de marrakech et donc est là
elle était dans le tournage se placer là
donc ils avaient la responsabilité du
tournage que tout se passe bien et c est
ça n'a pas manqué je crois qu'il est
tombé amoureux de de la comédienne
principale voilà voilà alors elle épouse
son prince charmant dans le plus grand
secret et pendant six ans personne va se
douter qu'ils sont sains et les femmes
enfin c'est pacha surtout qu'ils
n'étaient pas au courant et qui a priori
n'était pas tout à fait d'accord pour
cette union ça c'est une vente est assez
vite et je pense que le pacha fait
semblant de ne pas savoir d'accord votre
mère à l'époque s'installe dans la
propriété du moulin bleu vert tournant
c'est ça voilà alors pendant sa
grossesse elle éprouve le besoin de
faire quelque chose elle commence à
dessiner alors au départ pour elle même
pour le plaisir quoi et ensuite très
rapidement elle se met à faire des
livres pour enfants voilà c'est à dire
qu'en fait est là elle a rencontré d un
éditeur que ça fait emile paul à
l'époque qui trouvaient ses dessins un
formidable et élus ont proposé de
dialoguer tout ça d'en faire une
histoire et ça ça a bien marché vous
naissez en 1956 donc votre mère
dites-vous à l'époque il a un teint de
petits pains sortant du four ces jeux là
ça vous me l'apprenez mais trois ans
plus tard vos parents décident de
divorcer d'un commun accord oui je pense
que
mon père a mal vécu son exil et puis
voilà c'est la vie de couple moderne
malheureusement ça arrive assez
régulièrement et là votre mère lance un
défi à des moeurs remontant à des à des
millénaires elle veut garder l'enfant
alors ce qui est contraire à la loi
coranique en fait parce que l'enfant
appartient au père il reste avec le père
et elle décide de s'opposer à ça elle ne
veut pas que vous soyez arraché au
moulin bleu pour être élevés à la
marocaine oui enfin un trade très
honnêtement ça s'est passé calmement un
jour mon père et a fait des études à
l'école des rushes et c'est donc bref il
était civilisé partout mais il
comprenait très bien que maman elle me
garder et puis voilà c'était d'un commun
accord
j'ai pas vu beaucoup mon papa c'est vrai
mais c'était comme ça je veux dire il
n'y avait pas de conflits de wuala
souviens c'était pas a dit à son mari
brahim tu verras ton fils autant que tu
le voudra et autant que lui le voudra
mais je le gardais donc vous êtes resté
avec votre maman voilà au moulin blé ma
grand mère et votre grand mère alors
entre temps votre mère s'est inventé une
autre vie elle écrit elle réalisé vous
jouez alors elle commence tout seul avec
une petite caméra c'est presque du
cinéma amateur les acteurs c'était les
enfants du village
terres du village et puis ça prend de
l'ampleur jusqu'au moment où comme on
s'y intéresse alors vous avez quatre ans
lorsque vous jouez pour la première fois
pascal dans le premier opus de la série
des paul y voilà alors police et un
poney c'est un poney magnifique avec une
crinière blonde sublime et
donc voila moi pour moi c'était un
souvenir extraordinaire c'était des
vacances un passé à 4 ans je rencontrais
des copains il y avait un cirque il y
avait des animaux c'était le rêve que
vous aviez à poney en fait fiable et
barbara qui a inspiré poli mais vous
savez tout faire un parieur vous êtes
très bien aussi c'est vrai
alors ensuite vient la série belle et
sébastien alors là c'est un véritable
triomphe vous devenez un enfant star
enfin à l'époque on disait un enfant
vedette ouais vous êtes extrêmement
célèbres alors quelles ont été les
réactions d'abord votre réaction comment
vous avez vécu ça moi je n'étais pas
très conscient de ce qui se passait
enfin je veux dire quand on tourne à ce
genre de soalala ce que j'avais bon
d'abord les c'est une autre époque les
médias n'est pas aussi développé
qu'aujourd'hui tout le monde n'avait pas
envie de devenir célèbre en faisant la
star academy voila voila et moi surtout
pas c'était pas mon but du tout non je
me rendais pas compte de l'impact que ça
aurait après les normands non plus je
pense pas qu'elle pensait que ça
marcherait autant et que ça aurait un
tel retentissement met donc moi c'est
pareil je m'amusais beaucoup sur les
tournages je rencontrais des techniciens
je m'intéressais à tous j'étais pas
forcément très disciplinés pareil et
voilà non c'était c'était une éclade
total pour moi bon votre mère j'imagine
qu'elle était très heureuse de tout ça
oui météo elle aussi un petit peu
dépassé par par le par le succès par par
ce qui s'est passé par la suite dernier
un moment c'était un peu moins moins
sympa quoi et votre père il a réagi
commandes
je crois qu'il était fier moi je n'en ai
jamais parlé j'ai pas eu l'occasion
malheureusement d'en parler avec lui je
pense qu'il était fier de ce qui se
passe à ce qui se tenait au courant il
se renseigne et j'ai retrouvé des
courriers où justement il y avait la
question est ce que c'est bien pour pour
l'enfant etc donc il était déjà un petit
peu inquiet mais il était en même temps
sierre d'espacé alors les médias à
l'époque ce n'était pas comme maintenant
vous deviez faire des découvertes sûrs
de magazines mais enfin c'était moi
c'est beaucoup plus calme mais
finalement vous vivez une enfance simple
et chanceuse vous dites un trait à dire
que vous êtes au moulin bleu et prend
des cours de judo à dourdan et des cours
d'équitation à saint cyr oui c'était une
vie d'enfant rêver ouais ouais mais
alors il ya un truc dont vous gardez pas
un très bon souvenir c'est l'école des
frères des écoles chrétiennes un oui
parce que bon d'abord j'étais ado
et puis ça me convenait pas quoi il ya
des gens pour qui ça peut apporter
beaucoup
ça m'a apporté une certaine rigueur on
va dire mais c'est tout c'est vrai est
vrai se regardent pas un super beau
souvenir c'est gagner de l'argent à
l'époque belle et sébastien non pas du
tout avant pas du tout enfin c'était non
non c'était dérisoire et puis ce n'était
pas le but enfin je veux dire dans mon
cas de toute façon c'est de l'argent je
n'aurais touché 14 au rite est donc
entre 6 ans et 18 ans d'imaginer bien ça
fait ça fait pas grand chose et puis non
c'était pas du tout bien payés voyage
avait pas d'argent enfin je ne sais pas
organisés comme aujourd'hui ouais et
alors à l'école dû être la petite star
on vous aver toutes les filles alors
faute de goût non j'avais une sorte de
complexe au contraire je voulais essayer
d'être le plus discret de plus normal
possible la mode et j'avais j'avais
réussi en fait parce que les gamins au
bout d'un moment quand vous avez une
attitude normale justement ils oublient
totalement qui vous êtes et c'est
presque plus avec les profs que j'ai des
petits problèmes parce que dès qu'on
travaille moins bien foutu massip et
voilà on s'est dit ça y est lui il a la
grosse tête non ce n'est pas le cas
c'était simplement rejeté pas hyper
assidus à l'école j'étais pas très
bonnes et qu'il
était le meilleur moment de cette époque
c'est vrai que les tournages pour moi
était fantastique parce que je sortais
d'un milieu
scolaire enfin j'étais à l'école comme
tout le monde bon et puis l'été enfin
tous les deux étaient en plus ça c'était
pas un temps ça c'était tous les deux
ans étais je tourne et je crois que
c'est ça les meilleurs moments avec le
chien tous et puis vous avez eu la
chance de tourner avec charles vanel
dont sébastien et la marie morgane
engendre un coût ce qui ce qui est
incroyable c'est que charles vanel il
avait commencé bébé au sein des bébés
dont pour moi il était déjà vieux c'est
fou alors qu'il a tournée de l'âge de 3
ans en âge de cartes sont mises en c'est
un peu comme vous finalement si je
pouvais avoir sa longévité je serai très
fier avec quel était le pire moment de
toute cette époque mais j'étais très
protégé par la maman ouais peut-être
trop mais ce qui fait que j'ai pas senti
du tout n'est que l'expression ou la
jalousie etc par la suite après quand je
me suis un petit peu émancipé partir de
15 ans c'est un peu plus difficile mais
à cette époque là j'étais sur un petit
nuage j'étais très très protégé j'étais
très bien que vous étiez notre idole un
joli tout de suite alors ensuite fait
quelques films comme acteur ouais et
puis vous passez à la réalisation oui
j'apprends mon métier quoi à ce que j'ai
essayé de tenter l'idée que je me suis
fait jeter comme un malpropre
et puis j'étais assistant real de plein
de gens dont notamment yves robert et
puis j'ai fait des courts métrages voilà
évidemment votre carrière d'acteur et
s'est un peu ralentie quoi vous dit
quand ça s'arrête ça s'arrête quoi oui
bon je vais peut-être un peu cherché un
semaine j'ai pas l'habitude de mettre ça
sur le dos des autres je pense que je
suis en grande partie responsable c'est
à dire qu'à un moment j'ai cru que ça
allait continuer ouais et en fait c'est
un métier où il faut sans arrêt
faire du relationnel travailler
apprendre son métier parce que ça
s'apprend aussi métier de comédien bon
j'avais pas de bagages je tenais à
l'instinct et puis je me suis dit bah ça
va continuer comme ça mais en fait non
c'est plus laborieux plus difficile j'ai
quand même réussi à
travailler soit au théâtre soit comme
comme acteur relativement régulièrement
avec des longs trous mais je pense que
tous les acteurs ont connu ça on a des
périodes de un sur de longs bouts longue
inactivité malheureusement alors
aujourd'hui est ce que vous êtes
nostalgique de l'époque belle et
sébastien pas du tout sûr ravi d'avoir
vécu ça ouais surtout à cette époque là
j'aurais pas aimé le vivre aujourd'hui
le jour vous allez mourir qu'elle
voulait qu'on écrive sur votre tombe il
y ce serait sébastien s'est fait la
belle hausse et bien malin à c'est
vachement bien merci c'est très heureux
de rallumer la lumière sur vous même
bien ce merci à vous
[Musique]
j'accueille gilles de robien
sur le perron de l'elysée gilles de
robien savoure l'instant le coup de fil
de matignon lui il l'a reçu à 9h mardi
dernier c'est là qu'il a appris qu'il
était le nouveau ministre de
l'équipement et des transports je
remplis que d'émotions parce que on
participe quand même
à l'organisation collective de
l'exécutif du pays son ministère le
maire d'amiens n'a pas eu le temps de le
visiter
bonjour monsieur là
et c'est au pas de charge je fais le
tour du propriétaire visiter un petit
peu mais oui alors ça c'est le bureau du
ministre fan de jean claude gayssot je
suis pas obligé de garder le même bureau
mais aussi il faut d'abord ce soit
fonctionnel donc j'essaye pour l'instant
garder le bureau l'avait pas de raison
que je change et puis on vient
d'installer ce matin la photo ou ramener
ce matin la photo du président de la
république j'y tiens effectivement dans
dans le bureau du ministre est normal et
c'est républicain
tout le monde en a parlé à retrouver
gilles de robien à paris bonjour à
suivez moi je vais vous montrer mon
bureau
en bureau parisien
[Musique]
voilà donc maintenant j'ai bossé un peu
sur la région de ce soir parce qu'il
faut que je la cause les intéressent élu
pour un an président du conseil
d'administration du bureau international
du travail il alterne sa vie
professionnelle entre sa délégation
parisienne le bt à genève et ses
déplacements la réunion du jour est à
une heure d'ici dans une ville qui
connaît bien puisqu'il en a été le maire
donc maintenant je partira bien pour
rencontrer quelques personnes et
préparer la réunion de ce soir avec des
chefs d'entreprise où on va parler d'un
sujet qui est passionnant c'est la
responsabilité sociale des entreprises
donc je me prends un petit peu d' avance
et ça me permettra de passer aussi
les instants de détente gilles de robien
en profite donc pour faire un crochet
par qu'aux querelles son village natal
dans la somme il vient se ressourcer
dans sa maison de campagne casque était
joueur on a une heure alors je profite
on va lui faire un petit peu d'exercice
dans la campagne
pour se mettre en forme si je suis pas
allé pendant quinze jours si je viens
pas ici une journée ou deux pour marcher
je patine
[Musique]
superbe va traverser la somme envoyée
dans un autre paradis au milieu des
étangs des fameuses étant de l'essonne
je voulais
oh et y est
on va aller quand même bosser un peu
maintenant qu'on a un repris les
vitamines nécessaires
à une soirée j'espère intéressante on
aura beaucoup de beaux témoignages ou
quoi
[Musique]
je
monsieur hiver quand il avait bu leur
arrivée à amiens dont il a été maire à
deux reprises il ne peut s'empêcher de
faire un peu d'histoire de cette ville
qui lui est resté cher ici c'était un
champ de ruines sauf ce
parvis ouest avec la maison des pèlerins
tout le reste a été démolie pendant la
guerre tout je n'ai plus rien sauf la
maison du coin ça vous rassure mais
c'est une surprise quand on veut nous
voir
alors les papes et notre cathédrale on y
va parce qu'on est
vallée à l'est la visite est terminée
direction la chambre de commerce et
d'industrie pour une soirée bien chargé
et que
moi je suis un passionné il ya 200 250
chefs d'entreprise ici je défend des
idées sur le plan international et joie
ici des chefs d'entreprises qui vont
parler de responsabilité sociale des
entreprises là on rentre vraiment dans
le vif du sujet
j'ai essayé d'être le plus convaincant
possible pour garder leur mobilisation
intacte et pas les dissuader de
ce kit est cette responsabilité sociale
qu'ils éprouvent tous par exemple une
fois par an en en trois semaines au mois
de juin il ya 7000 personnes qui sont
des chefs d'état des chefs de
gouvernement des ministres du travail
qui viennent avec des délégations de
travailleurs
quelques jours plus tard de retour à
genève au bureau international du
travail gilles de robien doit
régulièrement il présidait le conseil
d'administration pourrait les réunions
qui regroupe les 183 états membres
nous félicitons tous pour cette
prestation et pour vos fonctions
nouvelles et son morcellement persuadé
que vous allez faire merveille
amiens paris genève quelle sera donc la
prochaine étape de son engagement
politique
[Musique]
à
et maintenant la lumière se rallume sur
gilles de robien gilles bienvenue sur le
plateau de tout le monde a parlé merci
alors vous êtes né le 10 avril 1941 à
coquerel dans la somme vous êtes le
vicomte gilles gautron de robien famille
bretonne catholique avec tout un la
particule les armoiries et la devise
sans vanité ni faible vous savez tout
alors il est où il y avait les champs la
forêt la demeure familiale
le château de coquerelles c'était le
plus grandes maisons du village ouais et
donc on l'appelle le château voilà oui
je sais alors vous dites ce passé ne
donne un supplément de 2 voire je sais
que je ne dois pas faillir
oui je pense qu'à partir du moment où
vous a donné beaucoup de choses dans la
vie ouais vous devez être d'une certaine
façon un peu exemplaire redevable est
redevable à la société dans votre père
jean de robien a toujours eu des
activités bénévoles à côté de ces
propriétés agricoles d'une famille
catholique en fait qu'ils appliquent ces
principes je dirais qu'à te dis que
social voilà très tournée vers les
autres là vous dites à la maison à
coquerel le clochard était toujours reçu
à table dans les communs une chambre
leur était réservé 1 est toujours et on
appelle ça m'a plu et on les appelle les
sdf ouais mais ils en passent beaucoup
ils ont passé beaucoup à la campagne il
restait deux jours trois jours quatre
jours
et puis ensuite ils reprenaient leur
chemin et on les avait notre table et
puis
puis ensuite on leur disait mais vous
devriez travailler en fait on sait très
bien qui s'est pas fait pour ça et
malheureusement dès qu'on leur disait
levya nous donner un coup de main dans
les champs à ce moment là on est à dire
prenez la route ni mais on les aimait
bien gras votre mère eliane le maire de
pas elle a passé la moitié de sa vie à
traîner en bottes à faire le catéchisme
dans le village et à se tuer à sonner
les cloches sonnaient les cloches et
puis à aller voir les gens à aller voir
les gens leur demander si ça va bien
leur rendre un service l'heure
les aider pour leurs enfants enfin
vraiment où tout ce qui était possible
et imaginable dans un village où
naturellement on se repose sur les
personnes existantes ont voyagé moins
dit on aller moins loin on n'avait pas
toujours l'hôpital on n'avait pas bon et
ressources et donc il ya plusieurs
personnes dans le village qui se
dévouaient dont ma mère et mon père
était maire du village alors votre maire
à 10 enfants à élever donc il y avait
des chamailleries elle vous disais mais
toi à la place de l'autre ah oui
toujours un des conduits à une
incompréhension il fallait toujours
qu'on essaye de se mettre dans la peau
de l'autre pour essayer de comprendre
les raisons pour lesquelles on n'était
pas d'accord un string mais c'est
quelque chose qui m'a un peu aidé un
guide alors votre mère vous rêvez
religieux elle vous disais tu es sûr que
tu n'as pas la vocation ça serait beau
quand même site avait la vocation ça
serait si bien oui j'ai testé j'ai testé
la vocation ou les retraites dans des
abbayes bénédictines
mais en réalité non il faut pas se
tromper sinon c'est une vie qui peut
être gâchée on est on n'est pas bien
dans dans sa peau et on est un mauvais
religieux donc non ça j'ai tout de suite
compris que j'avais autre chose à faire
que de que d'être ermite alors même si
votre père a été militaire en 14-18
d'état militaire si vous permettez à 17
ans quand on voit un jeune de 17 ans
aujourd'hui il ya un adolescent au post
adolescents à 17 ans il était engagé
volontaire comme beaucoup de français et
il s'est battu sur les fronts de verdun
il a gagné la croix de guerre et de la
valeur militaire mais à 17 ans servir un
canon avec trois ou quatre collègues
c'était quand même quelque chose
d'effrayant vraiment effrayant il est
revenu vivant et c'est un grand bonheur
une première grande chance qu'on a eu
dans la vie alors même si votre père
était militaire même si le maréchal
leclerc était un cousin de la famille
vous n'avez pas plus la vocation
militaire que religieuse non c'était pas
tout à fait compatible avec mon avec mon
goût pour les libertés alors à l'école
c'est pas un très bon élève à 20 heures
il ça vous empêchera pas de devenir
ministre de l'éducation nationale oui
mais c'est d'ailleurs les deux seules
années que j'ai fait à l'éducation
nationale vous avez qu'émile l'éducation
publique évidemment alors que vous avez
jamais mis les pieds dans une école
publique si sauf sauf pour l'année du
bac à baie mahault à versailles et là
j'ai une très bonne note en philo ce qui
a rattrapé les mauvaises notes en maths
en trio en langue est
alors à l'époque vous rêvez de devenir
avocat pénaliste des causes difficiles
un peu zorro contre les injustices c'est
les jeunes les enfants sont en général
très très sensible à la justice avec un
grand t à l'injustice ils veulent
combattre ça moi ça m'est resté au delà
de l'enfance et à 20 ans 25 ans cheveux
voyez bien avocat dès qu'on va dire
avocat des causes désespérées voilà mais
la tradition familiale que jamais la
politique vous avez un ancêtre qui a
présidé le parlement de bretagne
votre père était maire du village de
coquerelles et donc vous venez à la
politique au début des années 60 à la
mort de votre père oui j'étais passionné
par la politique je suis pas rentré en
politique tout de suite j'ai d'abord
fondé un foyer j'ai d'abord ensuite été
un vrai professionnel de l'assurance et
de la banque et finance mans donc
j'étais passionné pour la politique à 20
ans 21 ans 22 ans je demandais des
tickets d'entrée des billets d'entrée à
l'assemblée nationale pour suivre les
grands débats alors votre père lui il
était militant de la ligue nationaliste
des croix de feu comme beaucoup
d'anciens combattants de 14-18 du
colonel de laroque vous passionner pour
l'algérie française oui je me passionne
pour
la décolonisation et notamment pour
cette cause désespérée qui est bien sur
la colonisation mais en même temps je
suis très très ému par la façon dont ça
se passe vous dites je n'ai jamais
compris comment de gaulle avait pu
lâcher les français là bas abandonnée
comme on abandonne des bêtes dans une
arène rayons tout le monde à présent à
l'esprit ces images atroces des harkis
ou des familles de harkis qui qui essaie
de s'accrocher aux camions de l'armée
française qui s'en vont et en l'armée
française et la semaine certains soldats
qui tape à coups de crosse sur les
doigts pour que les gens lâche quelques
mois après avoir dit l'algérie doit être
française et donc ses sept ce réalisme
politique diront certains mais en même
temps ça durant la justice qui me fait
très très mal à une époque on est encore
un peu fragile quand on a 20 ans ma
soeur est encore plein d'illusions et la
realpolitik c'est pas tout à fait là les
causes qu'on épouse alors vous dites
quand j'avais un moment j'allais au
palais de justice suivent le procès de
salon c'est vrai j'essayais de
comprendre ce que ressentaient ces
personnes salah en jouant qu'ils avaient
été bien au-delà de leur devoir et qui
avait transgressé
les codes militaire pour essayer de
comprendre leur position et en même
temps d'écouter un
remarquable avocat qui s'appelait tixier
vignancour mais mon engagement s'arrêter
là n'allez jamais fait partie du jamais
l'occident et s'est jamais d'abord
j'étais trop jeune et puis ensuite
c'était un pas que je n'aurais pas
franchi parce que pour moi l'ordre
républicain ne doit pas
subir de d'exception et tout en essayant
de comprendre celles et ceux qui avaient
franchi le pas et pas que des militaires
d'ailleurs ce que de gaulle appelait un
quarteron de généraux factieux pour vous
n'étaient pas des faits l'ont fait il ne
faisait que c'est la question que je me
posais en permanence et qui motivait mon
approche et mes recherches et mes
lectures et quelque part aussi ma mon
indignation et ma révolte notamment
lorsqu'il ya eu des procès avec des
condamnations avoir des peines de mort
alors entrer vraiment politique avec la
campagne de giscard en 74 et c'est en
plus tard vivrait très mal
l'élection de françois mitterrand vous
retrouvez barricadés dans la permanence
de valéry giscard d'estaing a évoqué
quatre enfants ce qui m'a fait vraiment
mal c'est de voir l'état de la
démocratie dans d'autres pays que il y
avait des ouïes des hordes enfin des 500
à 800 milles personnes à la porte de
notre permanence qui siègent grimper aux
gouttières de taper dans les fenêtres
d'envoyer des des cailloux et des pavés
avec des chiffons enflammé imbibé
d'essence peut aussi être fiche le feu
dans cette maison que tu de maisons
amiénoise - à côté de la cathédrale et
dans cette maison il y avait mes quatre
enfants mon épouse mais il y avait ceux
passant à 150 ou 200 militants dont
certains ont pris des risques énormes
parce qu'ils se sont enfuis par les
toits et nous on était derrière la porte
pour empêcher cette horde de d'exciter
et davines et si ça peut l'excuser
quelque chose pour les empêcher de
pénétrer parce que la soirée était
peut-être déjà et ça aurait pu se
terminer par un drame ensuite vous serez
député de la somme maire d'amiens
ministre de l'équipement et des
transports dans le gouvernement raffarin
ministre de l'éducation nationale dans
le gouvernement villepin et vous
laisserez votre nom dans l'histoire
grâce à la fameuse loi robien donc est
une incitation fiscale à investir dans
l'immobilier sur l'immobilier oui on a
voulu vraiment relancer le logement et
les objectif c'était de faire quatre
cent cinquante mille logements par an on
a réussi à faire 435 milles logements
par an et donc d'un seul coup
le décollage de l'investissement locatif
ne s'est réalisé les premiers ministres
successifs jean pierre raffarin et
dominique de villepin ont mis de
l'argent sur les logements sociaux et on
a franchi la fameuse barre des 400
milles alors que quand je suis arrivée
au gouvernement on était à 2 199 195
villes donc on était enfin sur le le bon
le bon niveau pour que en dizaines
d'années si vous voulez le mal du
logement des 10 depuis en france est-ce
que c'est pas le must pour un homme
politique de laisser son nom à une loi
finalement on est très content ouais
mais attendant il faut relativiser parce
que ce sont les parlementaires qui la
vote et en général les lois qui sont
votées mettre beaucoup de temps à voir
leurs décrets d'application leur
circulaire d'application et on en voit
les résultats quelquefois deux ans ou
trois ans après pas éclater tout de
suite ça fait vraiment un ballon
d'oxygène pour l'immobilier il ya une
deuxième loi c'était une loi sur
l'aménagement du temps de travail elle
date de 96 elle a duré 15 ans parce que
il ya une alternance à ce moment-là et
martine aubry effet la réduction du
temps de travail pour tout le monde
cette loi avait très bien marché car
elle a créé 50 à 60 mille emplois
supplémentaires
d'après les services du ministère du
travail et elle a sauvé entre 30 et 40
mille emplois ce qui fait qu'il ya eu
cent mille chômeurs de moins en un an
grâce à la loi sur l'aménagement et
réduction du temps de travail qu'on
pensait bien sûr par des baisses de
charges sociales alors quand vous êtes
venu comme ça il sera politique assez
médiatique ça vous a plu cette célébrité
la célébrité je crois pas non parce que
c'est vraiment quelque chose de très
temporaire c'est les gens me croisent
encore dans la rue tout autant je vois
que des gens me reconnaissent ils savent
pas pourquoi ils savent pas si je suis
présentateur du 20h si je suis un homme
politique ou si une carrière dans je
sais pas quoi le cinéma ne savent pas
vous êtes qui vous
gilles de robien ah oui donc sa relative
oui ça relativise tout au fur et à
mesure que le temps passe franchement il
n'en reste pas grand chose de cette
entre guillemets célébrités quel était
le meilleur moment de cette époque mon
plus grand bonheur ça a été un jour en
visitant une usine tout au début de la
guerre de la mise en activité de la loi
sur l'aménagement réduction du temps de
travail il ya une dame dans une usine
mais qui et qui sait pas si pete est
dans mes bras à monsieur le ministre
monsieur le ministre que je suis
contente de vous voir et je n'étais pas
ministre à l'époque j'étais simple
député qui avait proposé une loi et qui
avait lieu à kiev été votée et cette
personne s'est mis à pleurer dans mes
bras en disant je suis un emploi robien
je suis un emploi revient grâce à vous
un j'ai un boulot
quel était le pire moment de toute cette
époque
c'est la fatigue et c'est la difficulté
de pas avoir suffisamment ses enfants
qui sont en âge d'adolescence et ces
moments compliqués fatigue en harassant
oui mais on n'a pas le droit de se
plaindre êtes nostalgique de cette
époque pas du tout un mode quand je vois
par exemple les ministres d'aujourd'hui
où ce l'année dernière
comment dire prendre à bras le corps
leur leur job et c'est pas le métier un
leurs fonctions je suis heureux je me
retrouve un peu mais je me dis je me
mettrais pas leur place à voilà donc il
ya une coupure au moment qu'il s'est
faite en 2007 2008 qui m'a manqué un
petit peu surtout quand vous avez quitté
la mairie voilà ça ça va ça m'a beaucoup
spectre marché parce qu'il ya un lien
affectif très très fort qui se passe
entre une population envers et puis bon
la loi démocratique est ainsi faite on
s'y attend on s'y prépare néanmoins
c'est quand même une blessure
c'était à refaire gilles qu'est-ce que
vous ne referiez pas pareil dans votre
vie
il ya un vote que je regrette et
aujourd'hui comme c'est d'avoir voté le
quinquennat moi j'aurais dû défendre le
septennat non renouvelables parce que je
crois qu'elle que soit le président de
la république un quinquennat le premier
quinquennat est occupé en trop grande
partie à préparer l'élection pour un
éventuel second et je crois que dans
notre
action politique ça quelque chose de
frustrant de gênant et on peut pas se
livrer la président de la république ou
un gouvernement ne se livre pas de la
même façon que s'il savait que
l'échéance à terme et est non
renouvelable maison que j'ai eu j'ai
fait l'erreur de voter pour le
quinquennat le jour vous allez mourir
qu'est-ce que les qu'on écrive sur votre
tombe ma tombe existe déjà un
rassurez-vous la russie elle-même pareil
je suis pas du tout pressé d'y aller en
dessous du don je voudrais de date la
date de naissance 1941 et puis 2041
comme ça je sois sans fin merci c'est
très sociable un bâillonnement merci
beaucoup merci
[Musique]
j'accueille somare a fool
à la fin des années 90 le nom d' omar
harfouch est associé à la plus
prestigieuse agence de mannequins
l'agencé élite j'avais une réputation en
ukraine et voulait ouvrir le pays parce
que c'est là où il ya des plus belles
baies du monde et puis ils ont vérifié
ils ont découvert que les frères à tous
repoussant les meilleurs et puis moi je
faisais un show à la télévision
diffusaient en direct les filles est
toute contente et ma motivation était
simple c'est que moi j'avais 20 % sur
les contrats de cette fille ciel un
million j'ai 200 milles donc vous
imaginez mais omar dit avoir fait un
plus gros coup en comme en l'an 2000 il
devient d'idylle un des patrons délit
joe casablanca se vient des états unis
me voir et me dit tu veux acheter mais
mes parts je le dis il me dit je vous
dis accord il m'aidait à un million je
vends je d'imiter fujian quand même
cerveau beaucoup plus me dit mais
personne ne veut aujourd'hui même 5e 5
semble s'allonger de moi je te donne
autant de millions je peux pas le dire
parce qu'il est citoyen américain et
j'ai signé un contrat là où je peux pas
dire ça mais je les données et m'a dit
métier tu es sérieux avait donné plus
donc que le million de dollars qu'il
réclamait beaucoup plus un
monde en a parlé à traverser l'océan
atlantique direction l'île très prisée
de saint barth pour retrouver l'homme
d'affaires franco libanais omar harfouch
en pleine promenade matinale romantique
c'est moi
ici c'est vraiment la liberté totale
ces sauvages ya pas de deux restaurants
de 2 comme on dit des trucs qui rappelle
un peu le capitalisme la société
propriétaire d'un groupe de
communication en ukraine le milliardaire
passe la plupart de son temps libre ici
j'ai l'habitude de faire l'aller-retour
et saint barth je peux pas ça fait
maintenant 12 ans que je vienne ici
enfin comment il se faisait avant
[Musique]
mais omar harfouch n'est pas du genre à
lézarder jusqu'à quatre par jour ce
passionné de sport pratiquer la planche
à voile sur une eau turquoise
[Musique]
mais la séance cette fois doit être
écourtée c'est une journée très spéciale
pour omar pas de temps à perdre il
prépare plusieurs surprises à sa petite
amie
[Musique]
la première d'entre elles est rouge un
beau cabriolet loué pour la journée
[Musique]
bravo et merci
forest la deuxième surprise en fait la
vraie c'est une demande faite à goulien
j'ai juste un petit cadeau à s'offrir
savoir toi
[Musique]
c'est pareil
ça
rené
et c'est donc fraîchement fiancée sur un
nuage que les amoureux poursuivre la
journée
en fait les livres quand des vraies
histoires souvent aussi c'est que ça
existe vraiment c'était il ya vraiment
ma princesse
ultime surprise omar emmène ioulia dans
une sublime maison au coeur de la forêt
tropicale
c'est une des plus vieilles maisons
17e
partout où il va oma rem louer les plus
belles demeures la visite commence
le piano il est des phoques
oh
à
ça
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
très grands dossiers pour une piscine
privée
[Musique]
et dernière étape de la visite la
chambre des futurs mariés et
ça c'est une chambre basse et c'est très
très beau
c'est la fin de la journée mais on m'a
réserve encore une surprise à sa fiancée
mannequin il l'emmène tout d'abord à une
séance maquillage
cette surprise c'est un shooting photo
omar est fasciné par la beauté des
femmes en 2010 il a d'ailleurs créé un
site pour faire découvrir des visages
comme celui de giulia il organise
également des concours de beauté et des
défilés
à la quarantaine omar harfouch est un
homme comblé quel sera donc son prochain
projet
[Musique]
et maintenant la lumière se rallume sur
omar harfouch omar bienvenue sur plateau
du monde a parlé merci vous êtes nine 20
avril 1969 à tripoli au liban père
professeur de littérature dans un
collège catholique qui il était pourtant
sunnite
écrivain est engagée politiquement il
avait été enlevé par les syriens au
moment de l'invasion du nord liban est
fébrile exactement mère directrice
d'école publique
alors enfance passée presque
exclusivement sous les bombes pendant la
guerre civile au liban vous dites on
allait à l'école la peur au ventre oui
parce qu'en risquer de tomber sur des
snipers et d'ailleurs on a été souvent
la cible des snipers et en risque est de
ne pas revenir à la maison vivent donc
c'était surtout le temps la mort nous
guette est partout votre seul refuge
c'est votre piano
et l'arrivée de votre piano sous une
pluie battante reste orale le souvenir
le plus marquant de votre enfance
finalement effectivement parce que le
piano était destiné à ma soeur aînée et
le jour de l'arrivée de ce piano déjà
tout le quartier le regarder bizarrement
parce que pendant la guerre qui va
penser à acheter un piano le piano
arrive je le regardais j'étais c'était
le coup de foudre au moins et c'était
pour ma soeur dont il faut les il
fallait pas toucher à ce piano et puis
un jour j'ai pris
l'initiative de touché et j'ai aimé ça
en fait vous êtes utile et carmélites
ensuite chez les frères saint jean
baptiste de la salle donc j'étais un
élève pas terrible il faut dire les
choses mais un pianiste prodige et à
l'époque votre rêve c'est de devenir
pianiste concertiste je passais mes
journées à lire la biographie de
pianiste compositeur et j'aimais surtout
les compositeurs soviétiques russes est
vraiment c'était mon rêve et je
m'entraînais en secret au départ parce
qu'à la maison de le matin il y avait
personne mes parents étant enseignant je
faisais l'école buissonnière pour
revenir à la maison jouets jusqu'au jour
où les voisins ont dit à mes parents
quand quoi votre fils il joue bien et là
c'était je pensais au scandale et puis
finalement mes parents même en mode et
de jouer ils ont aimé ce que je jouais
et un jour être remarqué dans un en
cours organisé par l'ambassade du rss à
beyrouth et vous gagné le droit d'aller
étudier la musique en ukraine
effectivement je pensais toujours que
les concours c'est truqué que ça peut
pas m'arriver j'ai participé comme ça
d'ailleurs en cachette à mes parents et
un jour une délégation de diplomates
soviétiques vient frapper à la porte en
demandant est-ce qu'on peut rencontrer
omar harfouch et il a participé au
concours il a gagné c'est un concours
pour tout le moyen orient et le prix
était un visa et un billet pour l'union
soviétique c'était bien soviétique à
l'époque et le départ était dans trois
jours cd me donnent un visa et demie
d'avion je devais déjà partir les
parents ils étaient scandalisés long
soviétique c'était un pays pauvre
pourquoi moscou alors que j'avais déjà
une bourse pour aller à aix en provence
en france pour faire des études de
musicologie moi j'ai dit non non c'est
l'union soviétique je vais aller là bas
c'est mon rêve et par là et chez party
et voilà le boulou quitté le liban à
l'âge de 15 ans donc mais alors vous
allez vite laissé tomber la musique pour
les affaires vous dites j'ai très peu
exercé mon métier de pianiste car j'ai
vite découvert que j'étais un mauvais
interprète alors c'est quoi je tiens à
prodige où on les interprète alors
j'étais un prodige pour le moyen orient
mais quand je suis arrivé au
conservatoire de moscou tchaïkovski est
le plus grand et le plus important du
monde j'ai découvert que j'étais
je n'avais pas la technique il faut
savoir que j'étais en classe avec evgeny
kissin aujourd'hui est le plus grand
pianiste au monde donc bien sûr que
j'avais pas la technique je n'ai pas
commencé à l'âge de trois ans de faire
des pieds d'eau mais j'ai quand même
essayé j'ai fait des études pendant cinq
ans et puis un jour j'ai découvert que
je serai pas un grand pianiste donc
autant penser à faire autre chose à
faire autre chose là vous faites des
affaires parce qu'en 1994 j'avais
rencontré léonid koutchma le président
du gym d'armement en ukraine avec qui
vous étiez liés et ce coup de chemin
devient président de la république en
ukraine donc coup de bol quand j'ai
rencontré koutchma il était juste
directeur d'une usine secrète parce que
c'est là bas où on fabrique et les
missiles nucléaires mais également la
station mir et donc j'étais le premier
étranger qui rencontre et je me souviens
qu'une fois je lis tenu à un dollar
américain il n'avait pas le droit de
toucher moi je les tournées comme ça
parce qu'ils voient ce que c'est un
dollar américain et puis après l'union
soviétique s'éclate le cren devient par
hasard indépendants sont révolution sans
rien et puis il organise des élections
et lui en tant que directeur de la plus
grande usine industrielle
il devient candidat et moi je l'aide à
pendant ces élections ils gagnent voilà
il est aussi lié avec le futur premier
ministre va vous connaissez du monde en
ukraine bizarrement et là vous créez
votre première radio fm supernova est un
magazine dont qui s'appelle paparazzi en
1998 vous racheter pour l'ukraine et une
demi-douzaine d'autres pays la licence
du concours elite model look là ça va
très mal se terminer au départ ça se
passait bien j'organisais le concours en
ukraine on découvre que les blondes
n'était pas suédoise mais ukrainienne
aux russes et là je tombe sur des perles
cdd jeune fille de 16 ans qui d'un jour
à l'autre font de la publicité des plus
grandes marques du monde avec des
contrats de six cent mille dollars 1
million $ et c'est pour moi c'était
parfait on faisait des concours avec des
sponsors en arriver à 5 millions parfois
le concours juste avec le sponsoring
pour moi c'était du business je voulais
faire ça proprement et puis je découvre
en fait que ce qui se passait à l'
agence à paris et à milan et à new york
c'était loin de ce qu'imaginer ce que
j'imaginais et donc là je découvre quand
même le côté glauque de modelling encore
à l'époque y avait pas internet la
transparence etc après et m'ont pris
pour l'international s'étaient ingérées
62 pays et là j'ai dit écoutez les gars
en a des sponsors jusqu'à 11 millions il
faut qu'on fasse ça transparent parce
que s'il y aura un scandale sexuel aux
autres on va tout perdre et eux ils
m'ont dit nous non le sexe et la
priorité on fait ça pour le sexe et tout
le reste on s'en fout alors du coup on a
essayé j'ai essayé de leur convaincre
devant le sexe vous arrivez toujours à
coucher avec ses 24 pendant le concours
laissez les tranquilles ça n'a pas
marché ils ont continué à faire leur
système alors je demande à mes avocats
d'envoyer des lettres recommandées et là
c'était
la presse s'est intéressée et c'était le
clash médiatique c'est devenu connu dans
le monde entier entre votre radio votre
journal
elite model look vous gagner beaucoup
d'argent à l'époque je gagnais beaucoup
d'argent parce que je faisais des bonnes
choses il faut savoir que ayant un pied
en france je connaissais la télévision
du futur en ukraine c'est à dire je
voyais ce qui se passait en france quand
par exemple le magazine que j'ai fait en
ukraine c'était presque une copie d'un
magazine qui existait en france et quand
j'ai ouvert la radio fm l'afm n'existait
pas en ukraine non plus c'était que
programmer et donc j'étais toujours en
avance j'avais 10 ans d'avancé et donc
bien sûr que les sponsors et les
annonceurs venez en priorité vers moi
puis moi je voulais que faire des
affaires propres gagner pas beaucoup
d'argent un peu d'argent mais gagner
quand même et faire je rêvais quand même
de faire une une carrière internationale
dans les affaires comme tout le monde et
voilà en 2006 vous revenez donc sur le
devant de la scène dans une émission de
télé réalité qui s'appelle je suis une
célébrité sortez moi de là on a
évidemment le grand public vous
connaissez la c'est la gloire comment a
réagi votre entourage à ce moment là un
mes parents
ne regardez pas la télé réalité mon père
il est tout le temps dans ses livres il
savait pas ce que c'était au juste tout
ce qu'il savait c'est que j'étais parti
au brésil
comme une célébrité française disons il
était flatté d ans les médias vous ont
mal considérés finalement j'étais
toujours mal considéré parce que je suis
né au liban c'est déjà un grand défaut
et deuxième chose et fait fortune en
ukraine donc pour les gens aux les
français en général c'est déjà une
double faute être libanais c'est déjà
mal être mal née c'est déjà un escroc
déjà rien tout par ma naissance et faire
fortune en ukraine s'est tout de suite
la mafia la prostitution la drogue et
tout ça est donc tout de suite j'ai été
très mal vu et en général en france on
n'aime pas les gens qui réussit encore
moins ce qui vient de l'étranger j'ai
gagné beaucoup d'argent j'ai gagné pas
mal d'argent pourriez vous arrêter quand
je peux je travaille très petit rire en
réalité je travaille de temps en temps
quelques heures par jour et la plupart
du temps je suis au soleil je voyage
alors est-ce que vous avez rencontré
l'amour à travers tout ça j'ai été
souvent amoureux je tombe facilement
amoureux et à chaque fois comme si
c'était la première fois et la dernière
fois et j'aime beaucoup aimé
et j'aime quand même mais
avec une patience à dire j'aime beaucoup
la relation à deux là ont là où on
oublie le monde autour de nous on voyage
on fait l'amour on ne pense à rien
d'autre ça j'aime beaucoup quel a été le
meilleur moment toute cette époque c'est
à dire donc là sortez moi de là je suis
une célébrité en réalité l'émission qui
m'a marqué le plus c'est plus que je
suis une célébrité sortez moi de là
c'est une émission qui s'appelait tout
le monde en parle et c'était le début de
tout c'était j'étais personnes et d'un
seul coup je deviens quelqu'un grâce à
un passage de 15 minutes dans une
émission très regardée très apprécié et
très respectée voilà quel était le pire
moment là avec le recul je garde
vraiment que les meilleures choses et je
n'ai pas de rancune je n'ai pas de haine
et par exemple l'attentât avec une bombe
artisanale qui fait exploser la benne
clés de votre frère ami et associé walid
alors que dans votre magazine pas
paradis vous avez publié des révélations
sur l'enrichissement du fils de victor
iouchtchenko le leader de la révolution
orange celle d'être un mauvais souvenir
quand même bain en ukraine il y avait il
ya eu une révolution orange très
prometteuse qui parlait de la
transparence de la démocratie nous on
avait un magazine qui était le numéro 1
en ukraine on découvre que le fils du
président transparent et démocratique et
pro-occidentale d'un jour à l'autre et
la 180 millions de dollars sur son
compte il a 19 ans étudiant il ne fait
rien dans sa vie donc nous on peut pas
ne pas parler de ça en essayant de
parler de ça on reçoit des appels de
ministre de l'intérieur et autres en
disant il faut pas sortir ce sujet sinon
vous allez regretter quand on a envoyé
le sujet à l'imprimerie la voiture une
nouvelle bentley dernier modèle qui le
dit juste d'arriver la veille lendemain
elle a explosé et nous on habite en face
de président donc on a tout de suite
compris que c'était lui bon déjà il nous
a menacé lui même bien sûr pour moi
c'était une double de déception la
première c'est toute la tante de de ce
qu'il nous a promis
et bien sûr c'était une illusion et
deuxième chose c'est la peur parce que
ça a explosé en grade chez nous le bruit
était un
ah très impressionnant la voiture a
brûlé et donc pour moi c'était un moment
très très difficile effectivement de ma
vie parce qu'on a pensé à laisser tomber
l'ukraine à partir à l'étranger et
pendant cinq ans le président ukrainien
a mené une guerre pas possible ils
voulaient vider mais compte arrêter mon
business il n'a pas réussi et
heureusement hélas perdu les élections
et il est parti et maintenant ça va
maintenant ça va parce que le présent
qui a tellement en ukraine c'est
quelqu'un que j'ai aidé à l'époque de la
révolution orange je suis toujours resté
fidèle à lui est là quand il est revenu
il nous a remerciés avec mon frère il
non mon frère par décret présidentiel
président de la télévision nationale
ukrainienne et puis moi il me dit qu'est
ce que vous voulez je lui dis moi tout
ce que je veux c'est vivre
tranquillement quand il ya ma vie et
surtout libéré les migros bancaire parce
qu'ils ont été bloqués pendant cinq ans
vous êtes nostalgique aujourd'hui de
cette époque disons de la tv réalité de
tout le monde en parle enfin à l'époque
vous étiez sous le feu des projecteurs
en fait les projecteurs m'ont brûlé
m'ont fait très très mal j'ai compris au
départ je me disais que la le proverbe
français vivent cachés vivons heureux
était ridicule et puis si on a gagné de
l'argent il faut le montrer il faut puis
maintenant j'ai compris je me suis franc
6 et 10 ans et je serai de me cacher
pour vivre heureux et mais je regrette
pas non plus ce que j'ai fait parce que
sinon j'aurais rester toute ma vie le
petit libanais comme appelé c'est un
petit libanais et puis c'est tout
maintenant je le suis le grand libanais
mais je reste quand même du valais
vous avez de la rancune pour quelqu'un
oui
pour mes anciens associés de d'élite qui
avaient à l'époque fabrique quand même
des faux papiers de police pour me
mettre en cause
pour que pour me discréditer ça quand
même ça ça laisse un amertume et c'était
pas facile et iouchtchenko voulait
rouler ue-chine coup c'est un pauvre
gars il a fait une opération de botox
pour cela a été un bel homme obsédé par
les jeunes filles et tout ça ça a mal
tourné alors il a il a fait semblant
quand il s'est fait on pas sonné que les
russes voulaient le tuer et c'est un
must et juste des piqûres de botox qui
n'étaient pas de bonne qualité
en fait il me fait plus de la peine qu
autre chose alors si c'était à refaire
qu'est-ce que vous ne referiez pas
pareil aux mains
des gens déjà pour commencer à élite je
crois que je n'aurais pas fait les
révélations de l'époque j'aurais pu
peut-être rester à l'intérieur et
essayer de régler les choses de
l'intérieur mais sans vraiment l'annoncé
au grand public peut-être j'aurais pu
réussir à emmener élite dans une
situation meilleure parce qu'après mon
départ élite a fait faillite et elle
n'est plus la grande agence de
mannequins deuxième chose j'aurais
peut-être pas embrasser madame de
fontenay sur la bouche quand je les fais
les jours vous allez mourir cassoulet
comme l'écrivent sur votre tombe j'ai
fait dans de mes organes donc des je ne
sais pas ce que je vais devenir après
maman quand vous écrivez pas sortez moi
de là je suis une célébrité qui viendra
déjà pour le lire personne ne viendra
pas merci je suis très heureux de
rallumer la lumière soit merci
[Musique]
et maintenant j'accueille philippe dana
imaginez vous un dimanche matin vous
avez besoin urgent d'aller chercher un
pot de confiture pour finir votre petit
déjeuner seulement voilà il n'y a pas la
moindre trace de pots de confiture dans
votre maison ou dans votre appartement
et il faut donc aller dehors dans le
froid pour s'en procurer un même
problème chez les ours simplement les
ours n'aime pas trop la confiture il
préfère vous le savez le miel tous les
moyens vont être bons pour se procurer
un pot de miel
excusez moi
merci les cuillères
[Musique]
tout le monde en a parlé à retrouver
philippe dana de bon matin en terrasse
au coeur de la capitale elle est bien
orienté et dès qu'il ya un rayon de
soleil le matin c'est idéal
merci beaucoup
[Musique]
tu as
c'est dans ce quartier en fête
sorti de la maison de la radio j'adore
ça c'est le seizième sud c'est moins bon
que le nord
il est temps d'aller travailler mais
philippe s'offre une dernière comme
antilles
et oui la radio c'est bien moins
stressant que la télé à la radio c'est
cool parce qu'on peut arriver voilà je
me suis rasé parce qu'on
savait qu'on joyeux
mais contrairement à la télé où il faut
se maquiller
si on a fait la fête la veille ça se
voit
la radio c'est plutôt plus cool hein
[Applaudissements]
vous écoutez le midi 2 en direct sur le
move nous parlons des blogs aujourd'hui
en particulier des blogs consacrés à la
cuisine
c'est parti pour deux heures de direct
[Musique]
une émission toujours dans la bonne
humeur et c'est justement ce que sa
collaboratrice apprécié après il
faudrait que tu ailles dire du bien de
moi
c'est quelqu'un qui revendique le joyeux
bordel
derrière il a une énorme bouteille
l'expérience j'aime les gens qui n'ont
jamais trahi c'est extrêmement
déstabilisant bon d'accord merci
beaucoup dans trois minutes c'est
christophe traisnel
il est 14 heures mais la journée est
loin d'être terminée
on va tourner une séquence qui sera
destiné aux sites web dans lequel
maréchal ganache créé par albert algoud
un personnage haut en couleur va
raconter ses mémoires après philippe
dana le journaliste le voici metteur en
scène toujours détendu tu as pris la
juste quand huit mâts se
hisse à celui-là lui quand il se la joue
ce petit détail
et même un peu nostalgique d'ailleurs
s'être esprit ancien canal
canal
canal historique je suis très intrigués
de voir comment ça va rendre l'âme et je
pense qu'on est pas mal du tout pas le
temps de traîner philippe dana est très
demandé place maintenant à l'acteur pour
un tournage dans un lieu culte de nuit
parisienne exceptionnellement je vais
pas à gâcher je vais tourner un clip
de mon ami louis bertignac j'ai plein
des plus gros rôle du coup je suis le
barman
[Musique]
c'est très simple il ya
un rôle principal
c'est le barbare il est tout sauf un
chien c'est un bon copain fidèles mais
as-tu a bien parlé vient ici donnent la
main bien donne moi la main réussi à
acquérir trois profs formés dans la
voiture c'est encore de roncal quand on
se met aussi
[Musique]
et avant de rentrer philippe va chercher
quelques inspirations alléchante pour le
dîner auprès d'un ami
[Musique]
pleine action ça c'est bien on aurait
dit que c'est fait exprès exactement
j'ai tout cela ils vont sait patiner dès
maintenant le rap
c'est pas éliminer la elle commença de
mousse
et regarde la couleur bien fait vous
savez bien qu'on trouvera un endroit
sympa pour finir la journée regardez bon
on savait qu'un jour elle baille vidéo
merci de nous avoir accueillis
mise en appétit philippe dana rentre
enfin chez lui avant une nouvelle
journée marathon dès demain
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et maintenant la lumière se rallume sur
philippe dana salut d'alain bienvenu sur
le plateau de tout le monde a parlé
alors vous êtes né le 5 septembre 1959 à
boulogne billancourt et vous passerez
votre enfance à courbevoie
père directeur commercial dans une
société de bijouterie fantaisie c'est
vrai c'est une tradition familiale pas
du tout avant ça s'est fait comme ça
alors votre mère femme au foyer
exactement alors votre premier souvenir
de télévision c'est les premiers pas de
neil armstrong sur la lune en direct de
19 ans ouais ça c'est toute une
génération qui a fonctionné comme ça je
crois que c'était un événement tellement
spectaculaire ça se passait la nuit il
me semble que c'était la nuit et qu'on
était tous en train de vivre ce truc là
qu'était à ces dingos quand même comme
beaucoup d'animateurs de votre
génération vous allez commencer par les
radios libres un soir vous vous
retrouvez dans une fête dans les locaux
de radio ivre à côté du palace en fait
j'avais un copain avec qui je jouais au
tennis justement à courbevoie qui me dit
qu'est ce que tu fais ce soir est rien
et bien écoute viens avec moi je vais te
montrer un truc vraiment étonnant j'ai
des copains qui ont monté une radio
pirate est en fait c'était une bande de
vraiment c'était un côté très
libertaires et et le côté de cette fin
des années 70 avait des mecs qui
fumaient des pétards de partout et il y
avait un émetteur dans la salle de bain
et le studio dans le salon et des gens
qui passaient des 10 qui parlait c'était
un peu tout et n'importe quoi et quand
j'ai vu ça j'ai dit ouais ok c'est ce
qu'il veut faire radio yves qui après
fusionnera avec radio nova avec nova way
et d'ailleurs je vous rappelle que quand
on était installés dans les locaux dans
l'immeuble du palace une fois qu'on
avait filmé nos émissions c'était ça le
grand kiff quand même on avait 18 19 ans
on descendait même aux privilèges et on
y croisait et gainsbourg mick jagger
ardisson les gens de l'époque avait pas
vous faites quoi vous êtes à l'efap à ce
moment là non à l'époque je suis inscrit
en fac de
biologie à jussieu j'ai fait j'ai fait
une demi saison et on m'a demandé de
disséquer une grenouille et je n'ai pas
supporté dont j'ai arrêté là et après je
me suis inscrit en anglais à nanterre et
en fait ça je joue blanc des pas mal
mais je il y avait la radio en parallèle
donc en fait je savais déjà vais déjà
mon métier sur le tas après je me suis
inscrit à l'efap pour avoir un vague
diplôme on les femmes stériles golo
alors en octobre 1984 nous on met une
lettre de candidature à la secrétaire de
pierre lescure et qu'est-ce qui se passe
eh ben elle trouve que la lettre est
assez rigolote elle affiche dans son
bureau
ces relais ce curseur de son bureau il
voit la lettre qui est affiché et 10
écrit ce qu'on véronique là sur
l'assistante du bas c'est un petit jeune
qui voudrait vous rencontrer et donc
j'ai eu rendez-vous comme ça engagez pas
tout de suite ça a été un peu plus
compliqué que ça ils m'ont sorti pas mal
par la porte et j'ai réussi à rentrer
par la fenêtre et donc j'étais là au
début alors justement quand vous faites
vos débuts à canal+ c'est avec
christophe dechavanne alain chabat enfin
c'était quand même alain chabat c'était
le monsieur météo du soir un mois
j'avais été embauché pour faire la météo
le matin dans l'émission qui est l
émission matinale qu'animait michel
denisot et on avait besoin d'un titre
pour nous remplacer le week-end et avec
christophe qu'il faisait une rubrique de
gadgets un peu analogue à celle que fera
plus tard bonaldi et on est allé voir
nos patrons en l'occurrence lé patron de
la rédaction une bourgade éric gilbert
ont dit voilà ya christophe qui pourrait
nous remplacer le week-end est donc
entre novembre 84 et juin 85 les trois
monsieur météo c'était chabat dechavanne
et moi il ya une photo où on est dans
télé star sur les toits de météo france
c'est rigolo alors quand vous commencez
en monsieur météo et à partir de là vous
avez multiplié les expériences de
journalistes d'animateur de producteurs
vous faites dimanche en famille près
avec valérie payet ouais vous faites la
journée de la télé faisons appel aux
sociétés de production pour qu'on donne
le même budget à chaque set et
production on fixe un thème alors le
premier thème la première année c'était
la télé c'est toujours de la télé la
télé la télé de demain à la télé le
pouvoir et on reçoit des tonnes de
projets on sélectionne 20 tous financés
à parts égales et on les diffuse tous le
même jour alors que si on envoyait à la
mostra de venise aux golden globes au
festival de cannes enfin d'être un peu
le couteau suisse de la chaîne à ce
moment là je suis une sorte de couteau
suisse au festival de cannes j'étais
très vite choisi pour faire la voix off
de la cérémonie de clôture et en
parallèle j'ai été choisi pour faire la
voix off de la cérémonie des césar et
couteau suisse c'est ce à quoi sert un
couteau suisse a tout
fait aussi la fameuse voix off pour les
nuls l'émission ouais alain mais ça va
me croisent en compte qu'en fait c'était
comme ça canal à l'époque locaux son
petit et en fait on se croise et me dis
que tu pourrais nous filer un coup nous
on a besoin d'une voix off demain soir
pour la première tu fais la première tu
vas leur tu vas pas leur dire non pour
la deuxième non plus la deuxième puis
après tu es là tu d'accord et alors il
ya un truc qui était marrant sur les
nuls l'émission quand même il ya un film
qui a eu beaucoup de succès au cours de
l'année écoulée c'est des artistes dans
le générique de les nuls l'émission il
ya un type avec un blouson qui circulent
dans les couloirs qui est ce type c'est
michel hazanavicius away qui étaient
déjà là et qui était au parec était là
et qui bien plus tard fera des artistes
et votre émission la plus célèbre
restera ça cartoon le var a éventé avec
des toons alors en fait canal+ avait
acheté un stock de dessins animés à la
warner il les avait programmé pendant
l'été 85 ouais et la chaîne avait
remarqué des énormes pic d'audience
chacun qui passait juste avant 20h est
donc là alors c'est en deux mots en fête
alain de greef le patron des programmes
me demande de faire le pilote d'un jeu
ouais ce jeu ses stars quiz show ces le
pilote pierre lescure m'appelle dans son
bureau il me dit c'est bon on a choisi
tu vas animée star queen's a bien ok je
redescends à mon bureau quelques heures
plus tard le téléphone sonne pierre
lescure mme rose soit à nouveau une
ligne en écoute on a réfléchi finalement
non star quiz ce sera pas toi ce sera
philippe risoli et toi en revanche on a
pensé un truc que chabat devait faire
mais il a une autre idée les nuls donc
tu vas faire avec les dessins animés
de cartoon joe kay tu fera le lien entre
les différents programmes c'est comme ça
que ça se passait à l'époque est à une
heure de grande écoute en plus c'était
en contre programmation comme on dit
dans nos métiers mai à 19h30 le dimanche
face à 7 sur 7 et en fait ça a fait un
carton d'audience ou carton tout le
temps alors comme vous connaissez pas
grand chose vous essayez animé mais vous
êtes assez cultivé vous improvisé autour
des événements qui ont fait la mairie
way la grande dépression la guerre de
corée enfin heureusement j'espère qu'il
y avait quand même dans les cartoons
américains il ya une dimension
cinématographique c'est à dire que les
mecs qui ont fait ces cartoon il
côtoyait les grands noms de hollywood
des années 50 60 et par ailleurs un mec
comme frank tashlin qui a réalisé les
premiers bugs bunny ensuite il a fait la
blonde et moi avec jayne mansfield's il
a filé film de jerry lewis donc tu vois
qu'il y avait quand même une passerelle
et donc il y avait des références dans
les cartoons à l'actualité de l'époque
donc c'était facile pour moi et aux
personnages de l'époque c'est un peu les
guignols de l'éleveur quelques semaines
alors en plus le public de l'émission se
renouvellent en permanence c'est ce que
m'avait expliqué de grève parce que un
jour au bout de la troisième année je
les écoute tu sais on passe un peu
maintenant toujours les mêmes dessins
animés on les met dans un autre ordre
mais il m'a dit c'est pas grave du tout
chaque année il ya un nouveau public qui
arrive et c'est très bien l'émission a
duré 23 ans ouais c'est beaucoup je
crois que ces records nantes a les
chiffres et les lettres ah oui c'est
vrai je me suis tout c'est juste un jour
du seigneur et le jour du seigneur qui
lui aussi voit son public se renouveler
chaque année ouais mais diminue quand
alors évidemment donc là c'est la
célébrité c'est une émission qui marche
très très bien sur une chaîne qui est
extrêmement côté quelles ont été les
réactions de votre entourage dans ma
famille on est assez
fantaisiste donc en fait rien n'a
beaucoup d'importance et donc ça non
plus si tu veux moi je le voyais bien
qu'il y avait du monde qui voyait
l'émission je voyais bien que sur la
célébrité c'est pas un métier moi je
faisais mon job après que ça ait des
conséquences et qu'on te reconnais c'est
que ce soit d'un seul coup que ça
devienne cette scène devenue culte avec
le temps que va durer longtemps très
après non mon entourage a été
relativement était content de voir faire
ça ouais assez content mais en même
temps ce n'est pas l'euphorie
les relations avec les médias c'était
comment quand on est à canal à cette
époque là c'est pas dit si tu qu'on a
vraiment la carte les années 80-90
canal+ à la carte ça tourne à un moment
donné mais je sais exactement corps et
d'un seul coup on commence à nous parler
plus tout à fait de la même façon je les
ai vus dans des dîners où les gens
étaient savez - la carte l'argent venait
gagné j'étais salarié comme un salarié
lambda avec un très bon salaire certes
mais s'est jamais fait fortune et tant
mieux
l'amour salut vous rapporter des
conquêtes oui oui un peu papa pas plus
que ça regarde cette question coquine il
va réussir à faire rougir non béchir oui
si j'ai rencontré des femmes et finit
par épouser d'après c'est réglé
quel était le meilleur moment de cette
époque le tout début parce qu'on s'est
vraiment marrer si tu veux réunis là
dans un espace-temps unique ça
ressemblait à ce qui arrive dans les
médias de façon très épisodique ce qui
s'est passé avec le libé de serge july
oui tout ce qui s'est passé avec le
actuel de jean françois bizot tout à
fait il y avait le canal d'andré
rousselet et pierre lescure 20 84 94 au
début c'était vraiment une histoire de
potes et vers la fin c'était un peu les
borgia quand même avec de la drogue en
plus ou la wii pas pour vous mais non
pas pour moi non c'est pas mon style moi
je vois bien
le pire moment c'était quoi c'est la
période
deux jours narines et c'est le moment de
la de la world company le moment de la
fusion vivendi universal seagram le
moment où tous les gens que tu as connu
qui était à peu près normaux il ya
quelque chose qui déconne quand même pas
mal tous les repères sont perdus sont
bien qu' il ya quelque chose qui est en
train de se désintégrer mais à ton
niveau tarifaire bien sûr alors vous
quittez canal pourquoi moi j'ai failli
partir en 2000 comme beaucoup et xavier
couture mais notre effet vers président
juste après pierre lescure me dit mais
non on a besoin de toi tu es journaliste
tu pourrais aller à i télé et donc je me
suis retrouvé à i télé la chaîne d'info
où c'était très très bien les premières
années j'étais vraiment heureux et plus
vers la fin c'était moins bien et puis
un jour ils m'ont envoyé sur les
obsèques de claude berri ça je me
souviens au cimetière à bagneux
recueillir les réactions de ceux comme
le reporter de base alors si c'est quand
même pas dans un possible même à faire
ça je suis allé voir bertrand méheut je
sais j'ai au conseil de surveillance de
canal donc j'avais de bons rapports avec
votre président que les salariés aient
joué à bertrange dit écoutez moi je je
m'ennuie donc soit vous me trouvez un
truc qui m'intéresse dans groupe soit je
quitterai le groupe maggie bah allez
donc voir ailleurs mais très gentil non
mais tout ça en je garde de très bons
rapports avec lui avec le belle-mère et
je suis pas partie ni fâché et je pense
que j'ai bien fait vraiment c'était un
bon déclic j'étais très heureux de
partir aujourd'hui est-ce que vous êtes
nostalgique de l'époque canal lescure de
greffe non je vois j'aime bien voir
alain de greef on dîne ensemble une fois
tous les six mois quand il passe par
paris parce qu'on leur en général il est
plutôt dans sa campagne dans le luberon
mais nostalgie non il ne s'agissait pas
du tout et en mon nom mon état d'esprit
alors si c'était à refaire votre vie
qu'est-ce que vous ne referiez pas
pareil bas et non mais j'ai quand même
eu du bol non franchement quand tu
regardes le truc
je me suis retrouvée à 20 ans dans les
radios pirates à 24 ans à canal +
jusqu'à la cinquantaine arrivée chez
aidant je pense que je débarque le jeu
garde tous pareils tous par exemple
éventuellement je demande une
augmentation passé
et le jour vous allez mourir quel
souvenir qu'on écrive sur votre tombe
philippe bas ça car tombe c'est carton
mais c'est bien ou très bien
merci ce très heureux de rallumer la
lumière sur vous merci merci thierry
c'était tout le monde à la barre les
amis du parking bonsoir
[Musique]
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu